RAJEEV DAYAL: My name's
Rajeev Dayal.
I'm the tech lead on the Google
plugin for Eclipse.
And I'm here to talk to you
today about bringing the cloud
to your IDE with the Google
plugin for Eclipse
also known as GPE.
So there's a couple
links up there.
One's for session feedback,
and there's a
couple hashtags as well.
So please enter session feedback
and tweet about
things if you'd like to.
So let's just go through a
bit of an agenda here.
Just going to go through a brief
introduction, and then I
want to just sort
of talk about--
go through the set
of new features.
So really getting your code from
Google Project Hosting
into Eclipse using the Google
plugin for Eclipse, using
Google APIs in your project,
then finally deploying your
project to Google App
Engine using the
Google plugin for Eclipse.
And then a couple of bits.
They're new features.
They're a little smaller, but
I think they're important to
call out as well.
All right.
So first of all many of you
probably know, but I'll go
through this for a second.
What is the Google plugin
for Eclipse?
It's a collection of
plugins that work
with the Eclipse platform.
And the IDE is what people use
to write software, write Java
software or even C++ software,
but Java is what we care about
in this case.
And the plugins work with
Eclipse 3.4 all the way
through to 3.6.
And we'll have support for
Eclipse 3.7 very, very
quickly, and we should because
3.7 is being released in June.
And what the Google plugin for
Eclipse does is it assists in
the creation and development
of web apps that use the
Google Web Toolkit and
App Engine for Java.
Whenever you're using the
plugin, when you first install
it you'll have the option
to download the GWT
or App Engine SDKs.
You don't have to, but really
unless you have those SDKs
there's not a lot you can do.
One of our just general design
principles with using the
Google plugin for Eclipse is or
building the Google plugin
for Eclipse is blending
naturally into Eclipse.
So we weren't trying to be very
heavy-handed with the UI
and sort of take over large
swaths of area with like a new
dashboard or something
like that.
We were trying to really blend
naturally into Eclipse's DNA,
surfacing Wizards and features
in the right places.
Where you would expect
them to be.
And just make it easy for you to
just use these new features
we're using, building GWT
apps or App Engine apps.
OK, why are you here?
So I'll take some guesses.
So how many of you are Eclipse
users that are just
interested in GPE?
That's a lot of you guys.
So how many of you guys are GWT
or App Engine users that
are curious about the
new features in GPE?
OK.
And how about interested in
Google APIs and just want to
see how GPE can make
your life easier?
OK.
Cool.
My guesses weren't bad.
And for the others we
can talk later.
OK, let's first talk about
getting your code from Google
Project Hosting.
So what is Google Project
Hosting, right?
So I've given you the URL up
there, and basically what it
is is version control
in the cloud.
So you can go there and
basically you have a SVN or a
Mercurial repository that
lives in the cloud.
And you can view the repository
and commit logs in
your browser--
that's kind of the advantage of
having this sort of a VCS
system out in the cloud.
And you also get issue tracking,
a wiki, a project
homepage, and you don't have to
deal with all the headaches
of setting up your VCS server
and all those things.
So just to browse around
here really quickly.
Basically this is just the GWT
sample projects project.
Right?
And here's the home page.
Then you can sort of browse
through the sources here and
just go check things out.
So many of you are probably
familiar with this.
And then you can look through
the change log as
well, see the diffs.
So kind of cool that even if
you haven't checked out the
project, you can still see
differences and changes and
things like that.
So what I want to do is show
you how we've integrated in
GPE with Google Project
Hosting.
So unfortunately, things look
a little small, so what I'm
going to do is kind of like
post action, zoom in on
different things using this
wonderful trick on the Apple.
So I hope it doesn't give you
guys motion sickness.
I'll do the best I can.
So this is Eclipse, and up
here we've got the Google
plugin for Eclipse installed.
What I'm going to do is we've
got a little item here saying
import Google hosted project.
So I'm going to say
I want to do that.
First thing that happens
is it's going to
ask me to sign in.
Because what it's trying to do
here is figure out, OK well
who are you.
And once I know who you are,
then I can see what projects
you're a member of.
And then I'll give you an option
to check those out.
So I'm going to sign in here.
Now the next page is basically
saying, hey OK, that's great.
Now you've authenticated,
Google knows who I am.
But it's saying the Google
plugin for Eclipse wants
access to my Google Code
information and a
couple other things--
App Engine as well.
I'll tell you why later.
So in this case I'm going to
say, sure I want to do that.
I'm going to give it access.
And now let me just zoom
out here a little bit.
And on the left here you can
see the projects that I'm a
member of in Google Code.
So there's the GWT Eclipse
Plugin Project, and the GWT
Sample Projects, which
I just showed you.
On the right you can see just
a bit more information, like
my role of this project.
I'm an owner.
And it just gives me the
information that's provided on
the project home page.
So what I'm going to say is
I'll say, OK that's fine.
I want to grab something from
the GWT Sample Projects
repository.
Hit next here.
Now what you're getting here
is a view of the SVN
repository.
So I'm going to go under trunk,
and I'll see the Hello
World Project.
We're all familiar with
Hello World Project.
So I'm going to check
that one out.
Let me just zoom out
here a little bit.
And just hit finish here.
Basically what's happening now
is GPE sort of stepped out of
the mix and deferred over to,
in this case, Subclipse, and
has gone and checked out the
project version control, and
you can see it right here.
Basically this is the version
controlled project.
If you look at--
just go under the team menu,
you can see that
it's a shared project.
So just to recap here, what went
on is that GPE stepped in
and basically asked you for
your information, and then
using the Google Project Hosting
API we were able to
figure out what projects you're
a part of and lift
those for you.
Once you chose what project you
wanted, then we basically
punted things over to whatever
version control plugin you're
using, be it Subclipse,
Subversive or Mercurial to do
the heavy lifting.
Essentially check things out and
bring it in and create the
project in your work space.
One really interesting thing
for those of you that have
used Google Code is that the
username and password for a
repo is not the same as your
username and password that you
would use when you
sign into Google.
And that's for a good reason
because it's just supposed to
be more of a throwaway
password,
a little less secure.
But the problem with those
passwords are that they're
very esoteric.
They're not very easy
to remember.
Notice that you didn't have to
enter that at all there.
When we checked out the project,
the username and
password was set up and entered
for you by GPE.
So a couple other things
I want to say.
You know, you might say, well
what if I don't care about
Google Project Hosting at all.
I just don't want to
use it, whatever.
I think it sucks.
I don't know what you'll say.
But maybe you'll think that
you don't want to go and
install these version control
plugins up front.
Well you don't have to.
OK?
If you're not going to use
Google Project Hosting, you
can still install GPE, and only
when you go to use that
feature will you be asked
to, hey, install
some sort of VCS plugin.
There's also some work
that was done--
probably not noticed because
it's working well-- is that
Subclipse and Subversive don't
play very well together.
So installing them together
is not a very-- you
don't want to do that.
So GPE makes sure that in the
process of prompting you to
install these plugins that if
you already have one installed
it's not going to force you
to install the other one.
All of that's handled.
It's messy, but we took
the time to do that.
So just a couple other notes
here on the side for those of
you that are existing GPE users
or GWT and App Engine
users with GPE.
When you add a new project to
version control be sure to
commit the project, class app
and settings file so that when
you check it back out, GPE can
immediately recognize that
this is indeed a GWT or an App
Engine project and configure
it appropriately.
One thing that is often a hole
that people step into-- and I
don't blame them--
is the problem with classpath
containers.
So let me just show
you guys here.
So just to refresh what a
classpath container is.
Basically, you can see that
these things here are
classpath containers.
The JRE is one that you
all probably know.
This also is one.
The GWT SDK in this case.
So what is a classpath
container?
Really in the end it's
like a pointer.
So it's not really saying
exactly which jars are
supposed to be on the build
path; it's meant to be
resolved at build time
or run time.
So here's the trick.
Because GWT and App Engine
projects both use classpath
containers, they only get
resolved once a project is
checked out.
And what do they get
resolved to?
Well it depends on the SDKs
you have installed in your
work space.
So for example, if I have
GWT 2.3 installed,
I check in my project.
It's working well.
And then somebody else checks
out my project, and they have
GWT 2.4 installed, it's going
to bind to GWT 2.4.
Obviously, not something you
want, but that's kind of the
way classpath containers work.
So a couple of things
to notice to know
when this is happening.
If you look at the warnings
area-- hopefully you don't
have like 100 billion warnings
in your code, and this won't
get buried, but anyway-- look
in the warnings area.
And you might notice that
there's a message about the
WEB-INF/lib directory being
out of sync with
respect to the SDK.
That's a tip-off that you have
an SDK working against what it
wasn't intended to
work against.
Another option I think this is
probably the best option.
Get rid of the classpath
container entirely.
And just put the jars directly
on your build path and in
WEB-INF/lib as you need them.
And then GPE will still be able
to work with the project,
but then there's no ambiguity
about which jars you're
building against.
One thing to note for those of
you that use Maven, which is
probably a good set.
You don't have to worry about
this problem because the Palm
itself is always up-to-date,
and it just keeps things in
sync for you.
So you don't have to deal
with this issue.
All right.
So let's move on to using Google
APIs in your project.
So Google APIs, what are they?
I'm sure you've heard
of many of them.
There's a whole ton of them.
I couldn't name them
all if I tried.
So here's the list. Here's a URL
you can go to to see them.
Here's a few of the
usual suspects--
Map, Earth, YouTube,
Spreadsheets, Buzz and gmail.
So let me show you--
I'll just jump into the demo
here, and then we'll go back
and talk about what happened.
So first I'm going to create
a new project.
I'm just going to
create a new--
I'll just call this Buzz because
I'm going to import
the Buzz API.
I'll just call it
My Buzz Project.
And I'll put some default
package name.
I'll just make this a--
basically I'll just make
this an App Engine app.
So we've created this
project here.
So what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to say, hey, I want
to bring Google Buzz
into this project.
So what you can do, again,
if you zoom up here.
Or I'll zoom up here, and I'm
going to pick add Google APIs.
Let me just zoom out.
Basically now you have this list
of Google APIs that are
available for you to choose.
So you can see you've got
analytics, apps for your
domain, books, contacts,
finance.
And here on the right you have
a description of the API.
You've got the version.
You've got also links to
the API documentation.
So I could just click over here,
and that's going to jump
me over to--
whoops.
Zoom out here a bit.
This is going to jump me over
the documentation for the
Expert API for example.
Let me just go back
into Eclipse here.
So let's pick the Buzz API.
Right here, it's version v1.
It's still in Labs.
So I'm just going
to click finish.
All right, so what
happened there?
So let's look at the project
and just take a look.
Basically what happened in the
end is you'll see a new
classpath container was added.
And it's got Google Buzz.
And you can see the nice pretty
Buzz icon, which we're
really proud of actually.
If you look in here you can see
basically the jars that
were pulled down.
So here's really the main jar
that contains really the Buzz
API, but then you've also got
all the dependency jars.
And they're added
as a classpath
container to the project.
And the cool thing
is all of the--
you can look through
them here.
And you've got all of the Java
dock, all the sources linked,
and everything like that.
So basically in one click you
can go ahead, and you're ready
to code straight against
any of these APIs.
And more APIs is better.
Right?
So I mean let's go and add the
Books API because we could do
something with Buzz
and Books maybe.
So basically, you can
just keep adding--
you can add multiple APIs to
your project as you see fit.
It's just a really easy
way to get the
APIs into your project.
So just to talk a little bit
about what happened there.
What we've got is basically
just a service out there
running that gives a list of--
that's giving a list of
basically available APIs that is
based on the API Discovery
service that was announced
earlier this morning by the
Google APIs team.
What we've also got are
the API bundles.
You've got a bundling of the
API itself and all the
dependency jars.
And when you pick one, we
download it as a classpath
container, and it's added
to your build path.
The source is in
the Java dock.
It's linked for you.
And any jars that you need are
automatically copied to the
WEB-INF/lib directory.
So things are available on your
server's run time classpath.
Though I'm not showing it here,
notifications for API
updates, when new ones are
available-- or not new ones--
when new versions of the APIs
for your project are
available, will appear
right next to
the classpath container.
So that's an oft-asked
question.
When is the new version
of the API out?
Well now you'll know.
You don't have to ask.
It'll appear for you.
So one thing I kind of talked
a little bit about classpath
container resolution, and how
that was not great for storing
your projects in a repository.
Well the cool thing is it's not
in this case because if
you go back here, it's normally
a hidden directory
though I've shown it here.
You can see that there's this
Google APIs directory, and
that contains basically all
of the API jars that you
downloaded into your project.
And you'll see that Books
is here now too.
So it's safe to check things
in with the classpath
container because it's always
going to be resolved relative
to your project.
Just make sure you check in
the Google APIs directory.
So one thing I do
want to note.
In version 1 of this in GPE,
we haven't made a clear
distinction, as you may have
noticed in that list, between
server-side versus client-side
APIs or run time dependency.
What happens is with a
client-side API you generally
don't need to copy things into
WEB-INF/lib, but we're kind of
aggressively doing it anyway.
Because we haven't added
the metadata
to make that different.
So it's not possible--
though it is easily possible
to do that, we just haven't
done it yet.
So another thing is that when
you use Maven or just in
general, the run time classpath
is not equal to the
build time classpath and
that's not even--
And then in some cases there's
even differences between--
just different--
depends on what you're
compiling.
The build time classpaths
can vary
depending on the component.
But basically we're putting
everything on the build path.
We're being aggressive here.
So that's just one
thing to note.
You could exclude certain things
from it if you know the
API well enough.
One other thing is that you saw
that I added basically two
APIs to my project, and they
both have dependency jars.
You might think, well wouldn't
there be a nasty conflict if
they're using different versions
of dependency jars.
Well generally the thing is, at
least at this stage, when
there's going to be an update
for these APIs based on a
dependency jar--
say that's the thing
that changed--
then an update is going to be
available for all APIs that
use that jar.
So if you update and sync, you
should be fine, but it's
something to note.
All right, so one thing I just
want to go into here.
This is covered in a lot of
different talks, but I just
thought it would be worth
a couple slides.
So whenever you want to use an
API, you need to go to the API
console and enable it.
So just to show you what that
looks like, if you go to--
this is code.google.com,
API's console.
What you do is you
create a project.
And creating a project is no
more than just really creating
identifier.
And then here it's kind of
like a cool dashboard.
It feels like a switchboard
where you can just turn things
on and off.
And you kind of can actually.
You can turn on different
APIs.
And basically it tells you
what the quota limit is.
So once you do this-- the reason
why you have to do all
this is because in order to
use the API, you need a
developer key.
Now the developer key-- it
depends on what type of API
you're using.
If you're using an API that
doesn't actually need to get
any user data, so in the end,
Maps or something like that or
at least parts of Map,
then you just need
the simple API key.
However, if you're using an
API, like Buzz or gmail or
something, that's going to
require some user to give you
permission to access their data,
then you need to create
a client ID and a
client secret.
And you can go through
that flow here.
But do know that these are
things that you need to do
before you can actually
use the API.
I mean you can code against
it, and that's fine.
But you actually need to put
this information in if you
want to be able to use it.
So one thing to say about the
developer key and the client
ID, for server-side apps-- and
when I say a server-side app
in this context, I mean that
your server, your web server,
is contacting Google
services directly.
In a case like that, you want
the client ID and you want the
developer key to be secret in
terms of it shouldn't be
serverable by accident or
something like that.
For apps where you're using a
Java script API or a GWT API,
and basically the user's browser
is contacting Google
services directly, then
obviously you can't have a
secret anymore.
The developer key you still
have to enter, but it's
actually OK to put it out there
because it's tied to the
serving site's domain.
So it doesn't matter if
it's leaked to people.
They can't use it.
The one thing, just to go
back, that I mentioned.
Let's use Buzz as an example.
If your app is trying to display
Alice's Buzz post,
what do you need to do in order
to actually display--
you know, Google is the one that
has the Buzz data because
it's a service that
Google provides.
So at some point in the flow, if
your application is trying
to display Alice's Buzz post,
Alice has to prove her
identity to Google to say,
yes, I am indeed Alice.
And then she has to go ahead and
say, OK, I am Alice, but I
also give access to Bob's
application to display my Buzz
information.
So those two things
have to happen.
The way this is done with
Google's APIs is they use
OAuth basically.
And this is an open standard
that's implemented by Google,
Facebook, Twitter, a
number of others.
And it's meant to handle the
problem of delegated
authentication and
authorization.
Meaning that I have an
application, I want to display
information that another
user has stored
on some other service.
So at some point in using my
application I need to go talk
to that other service, get some
token back from them, and
then I can use it to talk
to the service and get
information on behalf
of the user.
So that's why in the end when
you're using an API like Buzz
or gmail, you need to go
ahead and use OAuth.
And you need a client ID
and a client secret.
And if you go back here you
can see with this big blue
button you can go through
that flow to do that.
And it'll guide you in terms
of what you need to do.
So not really specific to GPE
at this time, but it's just
worth noting that if you're
using the Google APIs, these
are things you do need to do.
OK, so if you want some
information on APIs and OAuth,
I've provided some links
here, like system talk.
So there's identity and data
access, open ID in OAuth.
That's already happened I think,
so I've given the short
link to that.
There's client login,
hashtag fail.
A little negative, but
you'll find out
why when you go there.
And that's today, just
a little later on.
And life of a Google API
developer as well.
All right, so just to roll it
all up because we kind of
jumped around with
a few things.
Basically with a single click in
GPE, you can see a list of
basically all the Google APIs
that are available to you to
code against.
With one more click, bringing
it down, you can
code against the API.
Though you didn't see it here,
you'll get push notifications
that updates are available.
And you can also
undo an update.
So you can update.
And if you find that it breaks
a bunch of things, like maybe
the APIs changed and you don't
feel like changing all your
code, you can just hit undo.
And basically it's going to
undo the change, and it's
going to bring back
the old API.
We keep this data around.
And finally, as I just noted,
make sure you use the API
console to enable APIs and get
developer IDs and client IDs
before you use them.
Otherwise you'll be restricted
by the quotas that are set.
OK, so let's go on
to App Engine.
Deploying your project
to Google App Engine.
So just a quick refresher
again.
So what is App Engine?
It's a cloud computing
platform.
You can write a web app in Java
or Python and basically
deploy it to the cloud.
And it'll end up living at
basically whatever your app ID
is .appspot.com.
If you have Google apps and
custom domains, then the
domain will be slightly
different.
So what does it provide you?
Basically it provides
you a heck of a lot.
You can basically write a web
app, have the code there, and
then that's all you
really need to do.
We're giving you the hardware
connectivity, the JVM, the
servlet container.
You have automatic scaling.
So as the traffic on your
application increases, more
front ends are spun up,
basically, to handle the
traffic and handle the load.
There's also distributed
memory caching.
So when you have front end
spinning up like this, one
issue is that they're
not very stateful.
Your lifetime is that of
basically a single request. So
what if you want to keep some
information around and have
another front end sort of know
about it, you can use Memcache
or this distributed
memory caching.
You've also got task queuing,
which lets you do all sorts of
things like offline processing,
or just have
another guy pick up
work that somebody
else posts to a queue.
So it's actually a really
cool platform.
There's a lot you can do.
And a lot has been added to it
in the past two years from
when it was released.
One thing you probably are
wondering about, security.
Well your app is definitely
isolated from
other running apps.
It runs in a sandbox that
basically restricts access to
the underlying OS.
So you can't do bad things to
interfere with other apps.
Certain JRE classes, if
you're using Java,
are kind of off limits.
So that you can't use certain
APIs that would affect the
file system, or other things
like that that could possibly
cause trouble.
So deploying to Google App
Engine, now in GPE--
this is not new-- you can deploy
to App Engine with a
single click.
But one cool thing is that with
App Engine 1.5.0., which
was announced I think like an
hour ago, there's a concept of
resident backends.
Resident backends are kind of
cool because you basically
have longer request deadlines.
So the request cycle for-- it
could be a day if you wanted
as opposed to 30 minutes.
The in-memory state, so if
you have static finals or
something like that, it can be
kept-- or not static finals,
just static-- it can
be kept around.
You don't have to worry about
it being purged after the
request is done.
Another really cool thing
is they're individually
addressable.
You can actually address a
backend just like as a
straight-up server.
I don't want to go all the way
into-- just because there's a
lot to talk about-- but there
was an App Engine backend talk
about an hour ago.
I provided the link here.
So you guys should check it
out if you're interested.
But the really cool thing I
wanted to mention is deploying
to backends is now
supported by GPE.
So let me just show you that
here really quickly.
So if I go back here
and we look the--
there's a project called
Hello Server.
This is basically one
of the demo projects
that App Engine has.
It's basically a pretty simple
App Engine project.
And really, it looks very much
the same as any other App
Engine project.
The only difference here
is backends.xml.
So in addition to App Engine Web
XML you have backends.xml.
And what this is defining is
just three different backends.
They're creatively named
small, medium and big.
And there's different classes.
Basically B1 means you can--
different classes of backends
have different
CPU and memory limits.
So B1 is the smallest, and then
B4 is bigger, and then I
think they have up to B8.
You have other options like do
you want it to be publicly
addressable.
How many instances you want.
So there's all sorts
of things.
So now what you can do, you can
hit deploy up here-- just
to zoom in up here--
deploy to App Engine.
And just zoom in here
a little bit.
And what it's letting you choose
is, OK I noticed that
this project has backends.
Do you want to deploy the
frontend, do you want it to
deploy the backend, or just
some subset thereof?
And in this case we'll maybe
just deploy maybe to the small
backend and the frontend
and just hit deploy.
And you can just see how it's
going through the process.
It's going to deploy things in
sequence because the sequence
may be important, depending on
how you set up your backends.
So yeah.
We added support for this just
within the past couple weeks.
One thing is if you go here,
just to show you, for example,
the medium--
I told you that the app is
kind of running here--
at rdayal-test.appspot.com.
But I did name a backend medium,
so I can just call
this like medium.rdayal-test.
And it says it's the first
instance because I had
multiple instances.
I could also just address
the other instance.
So that's what I meant by
individually addressable.
I won't go into it too much, but
you can see that backends
really are just like servers
that you can access.
In terms of what's going
on there a little bit.
So GPE, we're just using an API
provided by the App Engine
SDK to upload the app.
That's exactly what's
going on here.
Notice that no
application-specific passwords
were actually necessary.
You may have heard--
and this goes back to the
client login fail talk a
little bit--
that at some point we basically
had said, OK look,
it's really insecure for you to
put in your full username
and password to just deploy
something up to App Engine.
So we want you to create an
application-specific password,
which is a good thing.
But the problem is they're
kind of one-time use.
So they're sort of meant things
that store the password
and reuse it over time, like
maybe your Android phone
syncing and things like that.
But the problem with GPE is
since we never saved your
password, you would
have to enter this
password every time.
Or you'd have to go regenerate a
new one after using it once.
So one thing that we did, if
you notice, because when I
first logged in down here--
let me just pull up
Eclipse here.
Whoops.
So when I first logged in down
here, you remember that it
asked me for my App Engine--
if I wanted to give it
access to App Engine.
That's why.
So now I can deploy to Google,
and I didn't have to enter my
password again.
And just a bit on backends.xml,
the way we use
it is it just lets us know
that there's backends to
deploy so that we can figure
out the right sequence to
deploy them in and call
the API properly.
That's really what we're
doing there.
One thing I wanted to mention
is backends are-- you can
manually start and stop them.
I didn't mention that.
But the deployment of a backend
through GPE will
automatically start up
backend for you.
Like will automatically
start them up so
they're live and running.
One thing to note, if you want
to use backends you have to be
using App Engine 1.5.0.
So that's one thing to note.
So just a couple other things
about just general GWT and App
Engine for-- maybe some of you
guys may know this if you're
using GPE and GWT.
If you're using GWT and App
Engine, and you do a
deployment, the GWT compile is
going to happen automatically
for you before you deploy.
And we do checking to make sure
that recompilations--
that we're not re-compiling
unless we absolutely need to.
Things are dirty.
So we do that.
One thing to notice is
that ORM support--
App Engine supports ORM, but
it's automatically on.
We basically assume you're
going to be using it.
If you're not going to be using
it, you can basically--
there's a couple ways you can
do to speed things up a bit.
Speed things up in
development time.
You can exclude all of your code
from enhancement through
the App Engine preferences
in GPE.
Or you can totally disable the
enhancer builder and remove
any of the ORM related jars from
WEB-INF/lib, so they're
not uploaded when you deploy.
So that's sort of another thing
you can do to sort of
speed things up a bit.
One other thing just to notice
is that GPE, like with a GWT
and an App Engine project, it
doesn't distinguish between
server-side and client-side
code.
So in the end, you may be
getting aggressive validations
that are happening.
For example, the enhancer
builder may be trying to run
over the client-side code.
It finds nothing to enhance.
But in the end it's kind of
running over that because it's
not easy to distinguish between
client and server side
code unless you have
a convention.
Anyway, this is something that
we are planning to address,
but I just wanted to call it
out there just in case you
guys didn't know.
So just a couple of
other things.
I just wanted to talk
to, really quickly.
Just a few quick bits here,
other cool features.
So single sign on to
Google services.
I kind of mentioned
that before.
But if you're using App Engine,
and you're using
Project Hosting, we're asking
for permission to do that.
What we're doing is--
this is how you can
manage your login.
So I can sign out here
if I want to.
And if I sign back in, you'll
notice that it didn't--
this is actually one other thing
I wanted to mention.
One thing is that when you're on
a Mac using Safari, because
we're using the embedded
browser, it doesn't actually
clear out your credentials
necessarily on a logout.
So that's why it hasn't asked
me to re-sign in.
You would have to sign out
technically up here.
So let me just click
on that here.
So if I sign in here--
Whoops.
I think I jumped to
the wrong page.
That was odd.
Anyway, I'm sorry.
But anyway, the point is if you
sign in here-- we should
probably look at that-- but
it's asking you about App
Engine and Google Code in terms
of you want to give-- if
we ever add any other services,
we can basically
re-prompt you when you login
to ask you, oh, do you want
access to--
I don't know--
some other thing like that.
Just any other developer
service.
What we're doing is we're
basically keeping a OAuth
token that has access to
very specific scope.
So it has access to App Engine
and Google Code, but it
doesn't have access
to anything else.
So it's safer for us to sort of
store it locally for you.
So yeah, there's still the
chance it could be
compromised, but if it's being
compromised, the thing about
it is it really is only
a very limited set.
It doesn't give people
access to your
gmail or anything else.
The other thing is you
can kind of revoke
the credentials too.
So this page that I got jumped
to here by some bug actually,
but if you go to my account
in your normal--
If I go to authorizing
applications and sites, you
can see that it says Google
plugin for Eclipse.
And what I can do is I
can revoke access.
So if I revoke access like that,
it doesn't matter where
that token is.
It can't be used for
anything anymore.
So that's kind of the
cool thing about
using OAuth to do this.
So we don't have to worry
anymore about where does the
token live, what if
someone takes it.
You can revoke it from
wherever you are.
Another thing that's kind of
cool is that RPC tooling has
been added in GPE for the
Google Web Toolkit.
So just to tell you in three
seconds what the Google Web
Toolkit is.
It lets you develop and debug
your app in Java.
So you get all the benefits of
building an app in Java,
autocompletion, re-factoring.
It's a great debugging
experience, the great tooling.
Then you can cross-compile it
into Java script and HTML.
And then you can deploy it to
wherever you want on the web.
So the thing is GWT generally
deals with is mainly focused
on the client-side of things.
It's a client-side technology.
But it has both high level and
low level abstractions for
dealing with RPC.
You know, getting things back
over to the server.
So there's traditional GWT RPC,
which would do exactly
what you would expect.
You would call a certain
method on the server.
You'd pass some data there.
It would get executed.
And you'd get a response back.
So that's kind of the primary
RPC mechanism.
But there's also RequestFactory
as well.
RequestFactory is something
that was added in GWT 2.1.
It's sort of a higher level
abstraction over RPC.
Instead of having it
service-oriented, as in I want
to do this specific action or
call this specific method,
it's more data-oriented.
So most enterprise applications
have this idea of
just data entities.
All of them kind of do.
And what RequestFactory does is
builds the RPC around the
idea of the entity.
So it's more data-centric
instead of service-centric.
It also helps to address
the DAO problem.
It doesn't solve it, but at
least it automates some of the
whole conversion from a
server-side entity to the DAO,
marshaling it, coming back on
the other side, unmarshaling
it and then putting it
in your client model.
So it helps a lot with that.
The client data access layer
is easily derived from the
server layer.
So it's not just two very
foreign layers.
There's actually a lot of
similarities between them,
which is helpful.
And a really cool thing is that
it's kind of intelligent.
Only the smallest possible
payloads are
sent over the wire.
Only deltas of modified entities
are sent over.
So even if you request, hey, I
want rows 30 to 40, and you've
already requested rows 20 to 60,
then you're not going to
end up re-requesting rows.
You can request them, but
they're already there, so the
request won't happen again.
You don't have to manage
that for you.
Your RequestFactory does.
And actually it's
even smarter.
Only deltas of the modified
entities are sent over the
wire-- not even the whole
entire entity.
So it's got some pretty
smart stuff in there.
So just to show you
here, actually, in
terms of how this works--
let's just drop into
GPE for a second.
And I've got this project
here called Cloud Tasks.
And in Cloud Tasks, there's
an entity here basically.
This entity is a JPA entity.
It's very standard.
It's got tasks.
And then you've got name,
notes, due date.
You have some getters
and setters.
What you can do is you can say,
hey, I want to go ahead
and generate an RPC
service from this.
Go to next here.
And it says, OK, what do you
want to call this RPC service?
I'll call it CloudTaskService.
And I'm going to select the task
entity since that's the
one I have. The only
one in my project.
And I'll hit finish here.
So what happened there?
It basically generated a
bunch of code for me.
So let's go through and
just take a look at
what we've got here.
So here's still the entity.
That's unchanged.
But you've also basically
got what's called a--
if you look in the shared
folder down here--
you basically have the
proxy for tasks.
I'm going a little faster with
the terminology because I'm
not trying to dive really,
really deep into
RequestFactory, and
how it works.
There's a total other
talk on that.
But I just wanted to point these
things out to you so
when you do use RequestFactory,
you can see
that all the bits are
generated for you.
Basically you've got the proxy,
which is essentially
what you need to map the entity
on the client-side.
And then you've got
the interface, the
CloudTaskRequestFactory that
actually defines the interface
between the client
and the server.
And you've got the request
that's got create task, read
task, update task.
You've got the service name on
the server-side like what is
the service that actually
implements this.
And if you go under, let's
see, Cloud Task Server.
We've got CloudTaskService
here.
These are stubs because
obviously we don't know what
you want to do with them, but
we've generated the code.
And you've even got a locator.
So this is just about how do
you actually go ahead and
locate a certain entity
given an ID.
You've got a whole lot of--
RequestFactory is powerful,
but there are basically a
whole lot of different pieces.
There's an entity proxy, a
locator, a RequestFactory
interface, a service stub, like
a server-side skeleton
implementation.
You've got all of these pieces,
and you would normally
have to write them by hand, but
with GPE in just a couple
of clicks, everything
gets generated for
you, which is great.
Actually I'd recommend that you
check out-- it's already
happened, but you should
check out the
session later on video.
It's a highly productive GWT
talk if you're interested in
learning more about
RequestFactory and everything.
OK, let's just wrap up here.
So basically just wanted to--
a few things that we covered
just to highlight what
we went through here.
Or at least I hope that
I went through here.
But GPE makes it easy for
developers to leverage
Google's Cloud.
Google Project Hosting, Google
APIs and App Engine are just
very easy to use from the Google
plugin for Eclipse.
You saw that it's just really
a few clicks away.
The single sign on
functionality.
So there was a bug what that.
And we'll fix it.
It lets you manage
your credentials.
You can go ahead, and you can
manage them how you want.
You can manage them from the
Google accounts page.
So you don't have to worry about
us keeping credentials
around that you never can
take away or revoke.
Just whenever we add new
services, all that's going to
happen is we're just going to
say, OK, we know you already
have credentials, but we want to
give you access to be able
to-- or GPE wants to be able to
access this new service on
behalf of you.
Do you want to let us do that?
And you just have to grant
access or not.
That's all you need to do.
So it's a really easy onramp
for future Google service
integration.
And GPE 2.4 beta, which is kind
of what I was talking
about, it's a really good onramp
for things, like new
features in GWT and App Engine
that are actually pretty
powerful for building larger
scale apps, such as
RequestFactory, and using
App Engine backends.
They're newer features, but
we do support them.
Anyway, thanks a lot
for your time.
I appreciate you coming.
Go ahead and try the
GPE 2.4 beta.
This is where you can go get
the update site links.
And please provide any session
feedback if you can.
That would be great.
We've got time for for Q&A
if there's any questions.
[APPLAUSE]
RAJEEV DAYAL: Thanks.
I had a question about last year
in Google I/O, there was
a lot of talk about the
integration between GPE and
the Spring toolkit project.
And I was wondering what
ever happened to that?
RAJEEV DAYAL: The integration
between GPE and SpringSource?
Yeah, in the SpringSource.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah.
So basically it's
still out there.
We haven't actually committed
to any new
features as yet on that.
But that partnership still
does exist in terms of we
still are supporting Roo
generated GWT app and using
GPE in the SpringSource
tool suite.
So we still have the
partnership, but we haven't
committed to any new features
at this time.
OK, because last time, a couple
of months back when I
tried it, it didn't look like
ready for prime time.
So I was wondering whether it
was abandoned or still moving
forward, that particular
aspect.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Sorry, can
you repeat the last
part one more time?
When I tried it a couple of
months back, it didn't look
like it was ready
for prime time.
It wasn't working that well,
at least in my experience.
So I was curious where, because
we are adding so many
features in GPE, whatever
was happening to that.
Because Spring is one of the
most popular dependency
injection framework in the
enterprise Java world.
And if you are looking at
deploying your Java app to
Google App Engine, many
developers like me would look
at, oh, can I use Spring?
And that project looked
very promising.
But I don't hear anything
new about it
so I was just curious.
RAJEEV DAYAL: No, no.
It's a fair point.
And it's probably something we
need to talk about more about
what the future of
that actually is.
I'm sorry I don't have more
information for you though.
OK.
Thanks.
Hi.
I'm a relatively new user of the
Google plugin for Eclipse,
and I was using it last
night at my hotel.
And my internet connection went
down while I was trying
to deploy my app.
And then the plugin for Eclipse
popped up a little
dialogue and said, you need to
run a command line utility
adding app config rollback
to basically rollback the
half-submitted changes.
Are you planning on integrating
the rollback
functionality into the
plugin at some point?
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah.
I think we are.
We are actually.
We just have never exposed it.
But I mean there's really
nothing stopping us from doing
an automatic rollback in those
situations, especially if we
know that that's
a notification.
I think it's just something
we haven't done yet.
But sure, yeah.
That would not be
that hard to do.
Thanks.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Actually,
please file a--
I have another slide
here actually--
so if you look at the talk.
But yeah, please file a feature
request for it.
Thank you.
Quick question.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Sure.
I use 2.3 GPE, and I tried
the API library that
was available there.
In 2.4 does it support
uninstalling the API library
in case you--
I didn't see the ability
to do that.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yes,
yes, it does.
What you can do basically--
I could rip out everything
from [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
RAJEEV DAYAL: If you just say
remove from build path of the
classpath container, that'll
basically effectively
uninstall it.
Fair enough.
OK, thanks.
Hi.
I've got two questions.
One is you can only import
your own projects.
I mean sometimes I
find somebody--
I go to code.google.com
and find some project.
And I just want to check it out
just to kind of play with
it for a little bit.
And it'd be nice maybe if it
were possible for me to check
that out somehow, some way,
even if it is just in
read-only mode without commit.
RAJEEV DAYAL: Yeah, no
we totally agree.
I think it's just we need to add
a couple more hooks into
the Project Hosting API,
but that definitely is
something we can do.
OK.
And then my other thought is,
or my other question I guess
is, when you add a Google API,
if you use Maven or we use
Ivy, is there a way to have
those libraries pulled into
the Maven build or
the Ivy build?
RAJEEV DAYAL: Not yet.
So first of all, no.
Not yet.
But what we're trying to do is
we want to add a feature so
that when you do go and have
that list, and you add a
Google API on a Maven project,
it basically adds the right
dependencies in the palm
pointing to the right place.
So that's something that we want
to do in the near future.
Well and for that matter, I'll
use Ivy instead of Maven
because I don't like Maven.
And I've noticed that the Google
plugin for Eclipse
doesn't always like using the
Ivy container, the Ivy DE.
I don't know if that's ever
been something you've ever
looked at before.
RAJEEV DAYAL: We haven't
actually done--
as Maven support was sort of
newer for us in the past year.
We actually haven't taking a
deep look at Ivy as yet.
I'll be honest with you.